design in this sense really brings
together the various different
disciplines like biomechanical
engineering sports injury experts
material scientists all those this
disciplines are basically brought
together by the design and that's part
of the designers job to to integrate all
those in the spin into one holistic
product while I first start to do a
product design what I that basically do
is actually try to create a whole world
around the product first a kind of a
future world where there's an ideal
situation that I would like to achieve
and for this football shoe for example
you know part of that world was a sports
world where football players wound beats
injured so often anymore the Pele sports
23e was designed as a ultra lightweight
high-performance football shoe one of
the most important aspects on the shoe
is that it actually prevents injury to
the football player and the way we did
that was placing the studs to a more
awkward position and what it does there
is prevent the ankle from rolling over
in addition what we created with an
asymmetrical stud design and what it
does there is it allows the football
player to have grip in all directions
not only in a straight direction and
this is very important because the skill
of football play is often measured in an
explosive change of direction and not
only in running in a straight line the
top part of the shoe is created out of a
very lightweight synthetic material and
what it does there is it protects a shoe
of course from from the elements but it
also provides the boot with the
necessary support the market response
has been tremendous we got great
feedback from both professional football
players and amateur football players
they have exceptional price for the
outsole design which was something
different they didn't
and Cena before but they were confident
that they could actually play better
football in in those shoes and of course
if you consider that the marketplace has
it's actually quite filled already with
very big players it's actually very very
nice to receive that kind of feedback
because it shows that it's still
possible to do something new and
innovative even though there are many
big companies doing the same thing
already winning the presidency sign word
is a tremendous honor that's something
that really stimulates me through it as
well to to push further to create more
innovative products and hopefully they
might win the world again
you